Let's make the graph of another rational function,
because the examples are never superfluous.
Say we have y = x on x ^ 2 - x - 6.
First we will decompose the denominator
of multipliers, so that we can find the vertical asymptotes,
if available.
What are these two numbers multiplied
give minus 6 and their sum is minus 1?
They must have different characters.
Let me write my xs
a little closer.
One must be positive and the other one negative.
2 and 3 are quite close because the distance between them is 1
and I will draw the bigger number,
because I get negative when I gather them.
It seems that 3 x x 2 works.
A minus of 6 is obtained.
Minus 3x plus 2x.
Minus 3 x plus 2 x x
minus x, so it works.
This is equal to x on (x + 2) by (x - 3).
And as we saw in the previous video,
because (x + 2) is not abridged by anything
of the numerator and (x - 3) is not abridged by anything
of the numerator, we know they can
to be used for vertical asymptotes.
We have vertical asymptotes when either this or this member is 0,
because in these points the equation would be indefinite.
This is equal to 0 when x is equal to -2 and
this is equal to 0 when x is equal to plus 3.
We can try this here.
If x is equal to -2 or plus 3, we will get 0 in the denominator
and y will be indefinite.
Therefore, there is a vertical asymptote at x equal to -2.
Here is a vertical asymptote.
We will have another vertical asymptote at x = 3.
One two Three.
Here is the other vertical asymptote.
Now let's see there are horizontal asymptotes.
What Happens When x Happens
very positive or very negative?
As I said before, you just have to see
which is the highest rank in the numerator
and the highest degree in the denominator.
Note that the highest ranked member in the denominator is x per square,
and that in the numerator is only x.
What happens when x is very large?
Imagine we have something like a million
on a million per square, which is 1 per 1 million.
These articles are not important here.
But this article here will grow
faster than anything else.
It contains x per square.
When x increases, this article will grow faster than anything else,
including from this article above.
Therefore, it will approach 0.
When the denominator grows faster than the numerator,
the value of the expression is approaching 0.
Therefore, we have a horizontal asymptote at y being equal to 0.
I can draw this as a broken line on the x-axis.
Here is the line y = 0.
I repeat that we find this as
we look for which member is the highest.
The denominator is of a higher rank,
it will grow faster than the numerator.
You can try with your calculator.
And this is true as we move into a very negative or
very positive direction.
This will overcome this one above.
The denominator grows faster than the numerator,
especially when approaching 0.
We will get smaller fractions.
Just remember, 1 on 10 ...
What happens when x gets bigger?
Let me show you to my calculator.
Let x say that x equals 10.
10 divided by 10 per square minus 10.
You usually do not have to do this.
I just want to show you what logic says.
Oops!
I'm not trying to draw.
Let me get out of here.
If we have 10 on 10 per square minus 10 (again, usually
you will not have to do that).
I just want to show you, give you the logic.
Let me put brackets here.
I put brackets
here and here.
We get a small number.
What happens when x is even bigger?
Let's make it 100 instead of 10.
Let all 10 of us be 100.
We put 100 here and what do we get?
We get even less.
And if you try with x equal to 1000, the number
it will be even less.
And this is because this article is growing here
faster than any other member.
So we have a horizontal asymptote at y equal to 0.
Now that we have drawn the asymptotes,
let's try with some points.
Let's make a small table.
Here is the table.
When x is equal to 0, how much is y?
x is 0, we have 0 on all this.
0 minus 6, 0 on minus 6 is simply 0.
Let's try when x is 1,
how much is it?
I will write it here - we have 1 on
1 per square minus 1.
This is 0, so we have a minus 6.
And what do we have when x is equal to -1?
When x is equal to -1, we have -1
on -1 per square, which is 1, minus -1.
This is plus 1, so, minus -1, minus 6.
So what is that?
This is -1, so it will be -1 on 2
minus 6, minus 4.
That would be 1/4, so we'll get it
positive value.
So we have ... let's draw this.
Here is minus 1, here somewhere is 1/4.
It's somewhere here.
I will get a darker color.
We had the point (0; 0) and then at x = 1,
we had a minus 1/6.
We can continue to put points,
but it seems that when we go to the right asymmetry,
we are moving towards infinity.
And this should be logical.
Let's see, we move to
minus 2 on the right.
So, if we put minus 1.9999999, this article
must be a very small positive number.
And this article will be a negative number.
Minuses are shortening.
We have a very small positive number in the denominator.
1 on this gives us a very positive number.
As we approach the other vertical asymmetry on the left,
we will become increasingly negative.
The calculator tells me this because when I tried with
x = 1, I already had a negative value.
But you can imagine with 2.99999, right?
Let me draw a bit better.
Caught the idea.
If x equals 2,999, we get very close to the asymptote,
it will be positive, it will be negative,
this will be positive
and this will be a small number.
So we will have 1 on a very small negative number,
which, I suppose, is a very "negative" number.
This is -1 on a very small number, that is
we will move to minus infinity.
Now, let's try some point here and see what happens.
What happens when x = 4?
When x = 4, we have 4 on 16 minus 4 minus 6.
What is this?
This is 16 minus 10.
That's 6.
So this is equal to 4/6, which equals 2/3.
So at point 4, 2/3 is here, then 1, 2, 3, 4 ...
2/3, here's what.
It makes me think that I must approach
to the horizontal asymmetry when we go further.
Probably that way
we are getting closer to infinity.
Let me draw a bit clearer.
Like this.
You get the idea.
And here we are getting closer to
the horizontal asymmetry as we approach infinity.
This should be a better drawn curve.
I'm messing up here.
This should be a neat curve.
I think you understand.
Now, let's see what happens when x = -3.
When x = -3, we have -3 on -3 per square,
which is 9 minus -3, that is
plus 3 minus 6.
How equal is this?
This is equal to -3 on ... this is 12 minus 6 on
6, so what is equal to 1/2. So minus 3,
minus 1/2.
Minus 1/2 is here.
So we'll get to the asymptote when
values ​​become very negative.
And we'll probably go straight down, that's when
we are approaching this vertical asymptote here.
You can try with more points if you do not believe me.
But let's draw it to see if we are right.
Our equation is x divided by x ^ 2 - x - 6.
Let's make the chart.
Here.
-
That looks good.
Asymptote is 0 as we go down.
Vertical asymptote, bam!
We go up there, then back down,
and then again.
Here it looks exactly like our chart.
This calculator behaves strangely,
when we approach those values,
but it has the same general form.
We can narrow the set of function values ​​here,
if we want to make the chart.
Let's set a minimum value of x to 5.
And maximum value
let's also 5.
We're a little rushing here.
Now let's make the chart.
Bam!
Here!
This is the same curve we have drawn here.
I hope you enjoyed it.
-